a couple months ago i made a video
talking about the best way to make
desktop applications in c plus plus i
hate them a lot of you seem to like that
and wanted more content so here we are
today we're going to talk about walnut
something i made so in that last video
which i will have linked up there by the
way i recommend you check it out in that
video i basically just took the imgui
example and showed you how you can kind
of start building your own application
maybe using the examples that actually
come with the i'm going repository
however i mentioned that even though
that is like a good way to get started
is ultimately not how i would go about
building like my own application using i
am gui so what i was initially going to
do with this video is show you how you
can make your own application using i am
gui but i ended up going a little
further because last weekend me and my
team did lotum dev50 lotum dare is
basically a game jam we had 72 hours to
make a game from scratch anyway point
being after we actually shipped that
game we realized that we really do need
some kind of launcher so that people can
pick their graphics settings and without
getting too deep into the details the
way hazel is structured is if we wanted
to use hazel's ui library we would
basically have to include all of hazel
since it's all a static library that
would mean that like the launcher app
that launched the game would also
include the entirety of hazel and like
all of its modules such as physx anyway
point being i realized i really do need
like the best of hazel's ui library
which does use imgui but has a lot of
code on top of that i need that but like
standalone you know without like the
scripting engine without physx without
the hazel engine itself i just need like
the ui library so i can make a really
lightweight app and that's where walnut
was born so walnut is basically a simple
application framework that is built with
diam gui it's kind of built on top of it
and it's designed to be used with vulcan
meaning if you want to have some custom
vulcan stuff in there you absolutely can
and i've also added some utilities so
that we can for example load an image
display all of that stuff but you can
see that we can actually make an
application like this now technically
speaking this has like a custom title
bar which i haven't added to will not
just yet but that is planned the cool
thing about walnut is it's actually
using my own kind of custom forks of
diam gui and glfw so it does actually
include some code on top of that to
support like custom title bars and the
plan is to basically take this a little
bit further make it into a bit of a
series on this channel
implement some of these features and
build this into something that you can
easily use to make a nice looking
desktop application using imgui this is
also going to be used as the base kind
of library for some other exciting
projects that are going to be coming to
this channel very soon i'm going to link
this walnut repository in the
description below it's completely like
free for you guys to use you just have
to make sure that you have some kind of
version of visual studio the setup
scripts include support for 2022 because
that's what i'm using and also you'll
need the vulcan sdk installed now again
technically speaking if you don't want
to use vulkan you want to use something
like directx 12. it's very easy to adapt
this to use that because i'm gui also
includes an example for that but because
i typically use vulcan i thought i would
just make this vulcan okay so let's go
ahead and clone this and take a look at
how it works so git clone recursive we
need to get all of those sub modules and
we'll just clone it here into the walnut
directory now in this video what i'm
actually going to do apart from showing
you how to actually use walnut i'll take
you through some of like the
architecture of how i did this i
mentioned that i did this for like
forest the game that we kind of shipped
like last week so i literally did this
whole thing in about like six hours
meaning that it's not really a huge
amount of work and i should be able to
take you through it but i i still didn't
want to do it like from scratch in front
of you all because
it would take a few hours all of the
code is obviously inside the repository
so you should just be able to take a
look at that so let's go ahead and open
that directory here it is walnut the
first thing you have to do is just run
setup. inside the scripts directory that
should create the visual studio 22
solution if we go back and open up
walnut app.solution that is basically
like our that's already our app right if
we take a look at it here that is the
application if we look at this project
here we have core and dependencies you
don't even need to look at any of that
stuff we just have walnut app.cpp and
that is like the only source file
included here and that is a working
example if we just hit f5 to run that
you'll see that everything should
compile successfully and we get a
beautiful kind of application it's using
the roboto font instead of like the
default imgui one that font is actually
kind of embedded within the app so you
don't need to distribute the app with
the fonts this obviously contains all of
our custom code and if we go ahead and
actually look at the example you can see
what it does it's literally just these
kind of 38 lines of code as i mentioned
we'll talk about the architecture of how
this works a little bit later in this
video i'll have that timestamp but for
those of you who just want to use it you
obviously don't have to watch that part
we'll talk about that now so basically
if we look at the cpp file it's
important that we include entry point
and then we just have to basically write
a custom version of this function it's
called will not create application here
are your command line arguments and this
is how you set it up so you can see that
i'm using this kind of application
specification which right now just
contains the name and the width and
height of the window so here i'm just
setting the name to be walnut example
and then we basically just have to
create a walnut application and then add
like layers to it so this works very
similarly to how hazel works as well in
fact a lot of this kind of is inspired
from hazel we basically just push on a
layer the layer in this case just being
this little class that we've created
which has an onion gui render function
and then optionally if we want we can
set a menu bar callback so this is what
actually adds that kind of file menu
here which we have with the exit button
you don't have to have a file menu if i
just delete this and run it again then
you can see we just have no menu bar and
that's basically it so this kind of
function is just responsible for setting
up the application setting any settings
you might want and obviously pushing
layers menu bar call back that kind of
stuff as will not grows there'll
probably be additional stuff there as
well so let's take a look at this layer
so we have this layer called example
layer you can see it's a subclass of
walnut layer so at the moment a layer is
just this on attach on detach and onion
gui render function this gets called
when the layer gets pushed like onto the
layer stack that is what happens when
the application closes or the layer gets
removed and this happens every frame so
that we can actually render im gui stuff
to be honest this is kind of work in
progress i might just change this to be
called something like on ui render
because that might make a little bit
more sense in fact let's just quickly do
that now okay that's a little bit better
so on attach can obviously be used as
kind of a constructor now in this case
you can actually use a constructor
there's no reason why you should why you
need to use on attach unless maybe you
depend on other layers because at the
moment i mean what happens is push layer
just
like makes it and then immediately call
on attach anyway the reason why this
might be like useful in some instances
is because
possibly like vulcan may not be
initialized maybe at the point of view
creating this layer so again not that
you would do this but you can just
basically make the layer over here and
then if i make the layer over here but
then i just want to basically push that
layer back like this which you can also
do then at this point in time like there
is no vulcan so if i'm like trying to
load an image or something that won't
work however as soon as the application
gets created we do have vulcan so
because of this if you write your code
inside on attach then it will work
because it will only be called when we
actually push the layer and at that
point we obviously have an application
that's valid and all of that stuff so
that's why that kind of works that way
but for the most case it i guess it
doesn't really matter okay so if we add
this back in so over here is where all
of your imgu rendering code happens your
entire application really stems from
this layer this layer can obviously
create other class instances and you can
branch this out into your entire
application as long as all of the ui
rendering stuff obviously happens from
within here this is like all of i'm gui
here so if i want to like i don't know
add some text all of that will work
here's my text and then when it comes
time to actually distribute the
application you can see there is
actually a dist configuration if we
build that we won't get the console and
everything will be kind of optimized
we'll be compiling with optimization is
what i mean so here's our kind of dist
example and if i actually go to the
output of this so i'll go to build and
just find this area here you can see
there's no symbols there's no pdb
included in this at all we just have our
kind of walnut app.exe it's just a
standalone exe file everything is
statically compiled into that exe file i
can double click on it and there it is
that's my application that i can
distribute just a single exe file now
one of the things that i've actually
added to this which is kind of important
and doesn't come like i'm going doesn't
come with this out of the box is the
ability to actually load an image
because if i want to display some sort
of image here i mean gui does have some
code internally to like you know create
like a font atlas that it needs to
actually render text so it does kind of
use vulcan for that stuff but in general
like it doesn't come with any utility so
that's one of the things i really wanted
to do with walnut is have some useful
stuff so we have this kind of image
class that i've written now to be honest
a lot of this code has just been joined
from that font atlas stuff that i'm
going included i have gone through it
and made sure that like it does work
properly obviously for images and
there's two ways to actually create
images here you can either pass in a
file path and it will load it using stb
image or you can actually just give it a
width height format and a data pointer
and it will read it from some kind of
memory buffer this is useful because it
means we can actually generate like some
kind of image or texture or whatever and
then just display it so let's take a
look at a quick example of actually
loading an image so if i drop into the
working directory here i'll paste in an
image i have hazelgradientlogo.png
what i can do here is inside this class
as an example i'll just create a shared
pointer for this image and then i'm
going to load the image i'll just pass
in that file path and that's it so now
if i want to draw it using i'm gui this
is a walnut image obviously then all i
have to do i'll do it inside this window
here is just call i am gui image and
then image get descriptor set because
this i am texture id is just a pointer
to a descriptor set which is a vulcan
thing a vk descriptor set and this vk
descriptor set is just a pointer it's a
non-dispatchable handle so this is kind
of like what imgui expects when you
actually try and submit an image for it
to deal with and obviously obviously i'm
gui works with more than just falcon it
works with like opengl so for opengl as
an example this would just be like the
texture id however this is like a 64-bit
pointer and in fact i think there are
some issues if you try and compile i'm
going in like a 32-bit mode which is
rare these days but anyway the point is
it wants this descriptor set and then we
can give it like a a size right so we
can actually ask the image what its size
was so i'll just do that image get weird
image get height let's go ahead and cast
this to float as well and that is it
let's go ahead and run this application
i'm actually still running it here so
let me just close that run again and you
can see we have our image
there it is now one thing i didn't
mention is this is all by default inside
a dock space so you can actually take
this and dock it in you can obviously
drag these windows out they work as
expected let's go ahead and drop that in
here it's a normal kind of i'm gooey
dock space now most of the theme except
for the font is the default i'm going
theme i'm probably going to change this
as time goes on in fact i might make
some videos showing how to change that
let me know if you want to see those but
yeah that's pretty much like all there
is to it and don't really have much more
to say go ahead download it play around
with it let me know if you find any any
bugs or problems again i did make this
in like six hours i'm sure that there
will there will need to be some fixing
of certain things however it should work
pretty well i think now let's spend a
little bit of time diving into the
architecture taking a look at how it
works so what we have inside walnut is
uh only like a few files really im gui
build is an important file this is kind
of like a unity build of 2 cpp files so
these are just the actual vulcan and
glfw files that we need to compile
that are kind of the implementation of
i'm gui i guess that we'll be using
which in this case is the glfw and the
vulcan implementation now the reason why
this is here is because in dependencies
i am gui this kind of build script that
actually creates this which is just a
pre-make script that i have written over
here that doesn't include any back-ends
or anything like that the reason is we
might want to use it with something else
and i kind of those are just the imgui
files if you want a back-end you have to
compile it yourself which is what we're
doing using this i'm going build file so
that's what that is then we have the
application files again adapted from the
dim gui falcon example what i basically
did is if we go to imqe over here we can
go to backends and then we have
obviously like the
dot glfw.cpp and i think we have the
vulcan.cpp
now it's not even that actually because
we use those it's the examples and then
the examples glw vulcan it has a main
file if we look at that main file you'll
see these two are very similar now this
has an actual main function which my
version does not because that happens
elsewhere so this kind of what you see
here in the main function aside from
this like loop which is like the main
loop that stuff basically appears inside
the init function
so inside my application class we have
an init function again very very similar
i've added some stuff such as loading
like a custom font so we have i think
over here you can see the roboto font
gets added from memory because it's kind
of embedded into the actual binary
um but we load this from memory and then
we set that as the default font so
that's obviously new but mostly it's the
same right and then what you saw there
in this kind of while loop inside their
main.cpp example that just happens
inside the run loop with a few kind of
additional things right and in fact i
probably should clean up some of this
stuff but at the moment it's kind of
almost the same as what you see there
uh yeah obviously i've removed some of
their example code and all that stuff
and the cleanup happens on the inside
the shutdown function which uh gets
called by the destructor
over here
so
that's kind of just all i've done i've
kind of just made an object out of it
added some layer stuff the menu bar
callback obviously that only happens if
that is actually set so if you remove it
like i showed earlier you won't get a
menu bar
there's no way to like disable the dock
space or anything but that's obviously
fairly trivial to add
and then we have this kind of create
application
uh you know that which has to be
implemented by the client and that's
what we saw over here it's create
application function but we'll get to
that in a minute i've also added some
kind of vulcan useful things such as
like getting the vulcan instance getting
the physical device getting the regular
kind of logical device as well uh
getting a command buffer you can
arbitrarily write to as well as well as
flush that's important because that
brings us into the next kind of section
which is this image class that i've
added so this is like pretty basic as
well just a standard kind of vulcan uh
image we basically load it using stb um
sap image if you're uploading and not
creating from memory and then we
allocate the memory that we kind of need
this actually uses a staging buffer as
well so we can use gpu only memory i am
actually planning to add the velcro
memory allocator to this library as well
in the future because that's very very
useful to have obviously so um at the
moment though it doesn't use that it
just uses the kind of raw vulcan memory
stuff and then we set data which
basically which we can do by the way
like every frame or whatever we can
update the data you can see if it
doesn't have a staging buffer it will
create it then it will upload stuff to
the staging buffer and then it will use
like basically a vulcan command here to
well a welcome command list or a command
buffer to actually copy that um staging
buffer memory into
the gpu only memory which is kind of the
resident memory that it does here okay
so and that's using obviously that kind
of api application flush command buffer
which i have kind of provided over here
so those are kind of some extra things
that we need so that we can have images
and uh yeah then we just have the layer
class so that's pretty much it i've just
repacked a lot of the i'm gooey stuff
the entry point that i added as well
that's probably worth discussing it's
very similar to like the hazel entry
point and the one that's in the game
engine series i'll have that video
linked up there if you want to kind of
learn more about that because i explain
it in much more depth there the
difference is that if we uh well it only
supports windows at the moment
which is mentioned like in the readme
but uh
the important thing here is that if we
are in distribution since the way that
we like since we build this uh using the
windows kind of system so if we go to
link a system you can see in dist it's
windows that's like the subsystem but in
release and debug it's console right and
that gets set through the pre-make
scripts obviously so um because that's
the case we actually need to provide a
win main so win main and uh regular main
which is over here they both call walnut
main which is this and this actually has
its own kind of while application
running create the application app run
and delete app now why would this be in
a while loop typically again this while
loop only has one iteration but the
reason why this is useful is because
again it's adapted from hazel and in
hazel we've had some things where we
want to restart the editor for example
and by having it in this if we just kind
of uh you know if we just
you know terminate this application by
calling like the close function that it
has over here which basically just marks
running as false and then that run loop
will terminate then with this while loop
if we don't set that to false then once
it deletes the app it will loop back
around and create a new app right so
that way we can kind of restart it so
that's why that exists again not
probably the typical case but i guess
walnut does support restarting the app
if for whatever reason you need to
okay that's pretty much it i don't have
anything else i think to show hope you
guys enjoy using walnut let me know if
you want to see more i'm gui stuff in
the future i will as i mentioned
probably spend some time like showing
you how you can theme it and uh you know
we'll add some more stuff like that
custom title bar and all that i am
planning to do that and obviously as i
mentioned we will be using walnut for a
project very very soon on this channel
thank you guys for watching don't forget
to hit the like button if you enjoyed
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you